The first reactions to James Gunn's The Suicide
Squad are finally live.
Though the film is officially set to premiere
on August 6 on both HBO Max and in theaters,
several critics have had the privilege of
seeing it early - and their reactions are
getting fans even more excited.
The movie follows a team of supervillains
who are recruited to join the mysterious Task
Force X for a super-dangerous mission to defeat
monsters and enemies on the fictional island
of Corto Maltese.
Fans of the original Suicide Squad will enjoy
seeing some of their favorite characters return
for the newest iteration, including Harley
Quinn, Rick Flag, Captain Boomerang, and Amanda Waller.
This rendition will also feature several new
characters, such as Bloodsport, Peacemaker,
Blackguard, and King Shark.
"I'm not joining your Suicide Squad."
"We'll see."
Excitement for The Suicide Squad has only
grown with every new trailer drop and leaked
photo from the set.
As the premiere date quickly approaches, fans
are eager for updates on the upcoming film
— and the first reviews are sure to get
audiences pumped.
Though the original Suicide Squad received
lackluster reviews, it looks like the James
Gunn-led version is everything critics could've
hoped for.
Steven Weintraub of Collider tweeted,
"Absolutely loved #thesuicidesquad.
The movie is super violent, extremely funny,
and a huge home [run] for @JamesGunn and #DC.
Tons of surprises and things I wasn't expecting.
Just a great movie."
Umberto Gonzalez of The Wrap also had positive
things to say about the film, tweeting,
"#TheSuicideSquad is absolutely BUCK WILD!
I enjoyed the hell out of it.
James Gunn has easily made DC's most enjoyable
movie to date.
Visually stunning, action packed and full
of swagger."
One of the criticisms of 2016's Suicide Squad
was that fans felt it could've gone further
with the action, violence, and overall villainous
content.
Kirsten Acuna of Insider praised Gunn's direction
with a tweet that said,
"#TheSuicideSquad is probably the wildest,
wackiest, bloodiest comic book movie I've
ever seen.
Very clear they let James Gunn run wild and
not hold back.
Definitely gives Harley one of her best scenes
period."
The Suicide Squad has its fair share of doubters.
Nonetheless, even admitted skeptics conceded
that the film surpassed their expectations.
Kara Warner of People tweeted,
"So this skeptic loved #TheSuicideSquad.
It is balls to the wall *bonkers* in very
entertaining ways. i.e.
If you're wondering whether James Gunn and
that super rad @SuicideSquadWB cast would
truly go there w/ the material & the R-rating,
indeed they DO."
Ian Sandwell of Digital Spy also tweeted a
message to naysayers, writing,
"Any doubts you might have over #TheSuicideSquad
will vanish after the outrageous opening.
It's a violent, hilarious and unpredictable
blockbuster, and everyone will have their
own favourite from the terrific cast.
It's just so entertaining that you'll want
to see [it] again instantly."
Film critic Drew Taylor echoed Sandwell's
comment, writing,
"@JamesGunn's #TheSuicideSquad is gloriously
insane and so, so fun.
(After watching it, you'll think you might
have dreamed it.)
Everyone is excellent and deeply committed
to the material and its singular mood and
wild ass aesthetic.
Can't wait to ride this rollercoaster again."
The Suicide Squad is getting an overwhelming
amount of praise for its violent material,
along with its humor, heart, and stunning
visual effects.
Critic Brandon Davis's enthusiasm for The
Suicide Squad was obvious from his tweet:
"#TheSuicideSquad is absolutely insane.
Violent as hell, raunchy, unforgiving.
James Gunn is fully unleashed.
It's sometimes overwhelming.
It has moments of heart, humor, action, emotion...
all of it.
Relentless.
There's nothing like it.
Damn!"
Erik Davis of Rotten Tomatoes also noted the
stunning visuals of The Suicide Squad, tweeting that he
"had the BEST time watching #TheSuicideSquad
— it is a swing-for-the-fences kind of comic
book movie & I love that.
It's big, bold & visually stunning.
You will see James Gunn's horror roots splattered
all over this thing.
It's violent, but hilarious.
Angry, but also VERY sweet."
The Suicide Squad hits HBO Max and theaters
on August 6, so prepare yourself for some
epic butt-kicking, killer cinematography,
and James Gunn's signature sense of humor and style.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the latest
DC movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.